[Music]  foreign  [Music]  down towards the street guns in his left  hand black sweatshirt  a little deal  sir  put them normal  where is he  shows show me your address  you're gonna get shot  you're gonna get shot  you're gonna get shot  you're gonna get shot  yeah do it  you're gonna get shot  drop the gun or you won't get hurt  go  go  you're good  you're gonna get shot drop the gun  drop it  drop it  go you're gonna get shot if you go in  that car you're gonna get shot  you're gonna get shot  drop head  Sam 11 shots fired shots fired  the man was taken into custody and  received medical treatment at the scene  he was transported to a nearby hospital  by ambulance the man was later  pronounced deceased at the hospital  his identity is known but is being  withheld at this time thankfully The  woman Inside the car was not injured  during this incident  a loaded handgun was recovered at the  scene